nous sommes dans l'unité externalisée
d'heuliez mais ce raphaël babet à saint
joseph
c'est pendant ce jour d'école que
christopher concernés par la déficience
psychique peut quitter sa salle de
classe et se rendre dans la pièce juste
à côté
pour consulter son orthophoniste si
cette proximité est possible c'est grâce
à l'implantation de l'unité externalisée
dit une de l'e-mail sera fait à la baie
au sein de l'école primaire le neveu
c'est pourquoi à croquer oui ce sont des
enfants qui ont besoin de ça un enfant
qui a des besoins un petit peu similaire
et qui est dans une classe ordinaire va
se va aller au cabinet de
l'orthophoniste le soir après l'école ou
le mercredi
ces enfants là ils ont la chance d'avoir
leur prise en charge
l'orthophoniste qui vient faire sa prise
en charge sur place sur leur temps sur
l'établissement
cette organisation est un soulagement
pour les enfants mais aussi pour les
parents les époux paillettes les parents
d'eloïse le confirme
ça fait un gros changement déjà dans
dans sa vie tous les jours par rapport
il y avait il ya plus est contrainte de
taxi qui vient la chercher dans les
autres cours pour amener à l'auto
finisse
on est enfin de tous les intervenants
qu'ils assument et là maintenant tout
est sur place donc il n'y a pas cette
coupure ça continue depuis deux ans
l'unité analyse est implanté dans les
locaux de l'école primaire a que neuf
enfants porteurs de déficience mentale
ils sont encadrés à
la fois par un professeur des écoles
formés à ces publics et par une
éducatrice spécialisée de l'institut
médico social un tandem qui vise un
accompagnement adapté à chaque enfant
on essaye de répondre aux besoins de
chaque enfant donc ça c'est aussi bien
un besoins pédagogiques que 1 besoins
éducatifs c'est pour ça qu'on travaille
à deux on a des groupes moins chargé on
prend le temps on a moins de pression
sur les échéances de chaque enfant
l'enfant va aller là où il pourra aller
avec le temps qu'il mettra pour y aller
nous on suit le développement de
l'enfant et on essaie de voir jusqu'où
il est capable d'aller comme chaque jour
la journée comporte un moment de classes
mixtes
car au delà des connaissances à acquérir
le coût du projet de l'implantation et
l'inclusion des enfants porteurs de
handicap dans un milieu ordinaire
c'est à dire apprendre à vivre ensemble
dans la cité pour cela rien de mieux
qu'un atelier d'éveil
aujourd'hui ces pâtisseries ce qu'est ce
que vous préparez
un chocolat comment d'accord et après
vous allez le passé au four et ça doit
cuire combien de temps comment vous
savez ça l'adaptation elle passe par
plusieurs choses donc elle passe par la
socialisation c'est parce que j'ai fait
et puis aussi la sensibilisation des
autres enfants de l'école par rapport à
ce public
j'ai pu intervenir dans des classes de
cm2 parler du handicap et leur demandait
ce que pouvait être un handicap pour eux
donc ai eu plein dans le faux ça pouvait
être maladie ça pouvait être une des
choses qui ne sont pas du tout juste
donc il a fallu remettre les choses au
clair et puis aussi lors des inclusions
lorsque nous travaillons avec une classe
de ce2 comme ce matin et bien voilà il
découvre nos enfants 6e et 8e des grooms
et sait pas encore lire
oui mais c'est pas grave par contre
c'est bien faire la recette c'est bien
reconnaître les ingrédients qu'il faut
donc voilà après ils se rencontrent à ce
moment là
c'est bien d'être dans le way pourquoi
et la fin j'ai joué et est est ce que
c'est bien d'être mélangés avec les
enfants de deux classes c'est parce que
écrit à l'état la callas et j'aime bien
travailler
d'accord et c'est bien l'école
s'appelait l'école qu'est ce que tu
préfères à l'école destinée et anecdotes
et comme on l'appelle à terre d'accord
et americo peut aussi bien jouer avec
tes copains
c'est quoi les jeux quoi owen omer
d'accord et là tu veux avec tout le
monde ne sait pas que les enfants lieu
où en tout bon son de leur côté les
enfants dits ordinaires sans avoir aucun
problème pour comprendre et assimiler
cette démarche d'acceptation proposées
par l'établissement
et toi que toi tu es en vie de la zone
et oui
c'est pourquoi
parce que tous les enfants sont pareils
c'est juste que eux ils ont un handicap
et ben ça peut arriver à tout le monde
il ya des choses qu'ils arrivent à
refaire il ya des choses qu'on n'arrive
pas à faire augmenter
par exemple une recette qui sait savent
faire et non sa part faire et je vais
vous parler ensemble oui on joue parfois
la marelle
après deux années de fonctionnement les
équipes de l'établissement mesure déjà
les progrès l'évolution on a pu
constater nous justement c'est cette
adaptation et il ya de moins il ya deux
ans on va dire moins de critiques -
d'incompréhension par rapport aux
personnes porteuses de handicap
présentes dans l'établissement
c'est entre guillemets un objectif qu'on
a
réussi à réaliser c'est à dire que on
fait partie de l'école et nos enfants
sont à part entière dans le système
cependant l'éducation à l'ouverture
d'esprit est un travail quotidien
l'équipe de lille metz et de l'école
prévert le neveu le savent bien
ah non rien est acquis non non le long
hall on s'en aperçoit tous les jours
notre vie courante de
deux citoyens
la différence beaucoup de gens la
trouvent bizarre
la rejette la compagne par le salarié
insupportable le handicap social est
énorme
effectivement l'intégration les
inclusions le milieu doit aussi
s'adapter à nos jeunes mais nos jeunes
aussi s'adapter s'adapter au milieu et
ça c'est un enjeu un enjeu majeur qui
est au moins aussi important que
d'arriver à savoir lire écrire parce que
le vivre le vivre c'est pas seulement
lire écrire ou compter le vivre c'est
aussi être à l'aise dans sa peau avec
tout le monde